يرفرف العلم الاوكراني يوما ما امام مقر
النيتو مع باقي اعلام الدول الاعضاء
الثلاثين تبقى هذه رغبه الحكومه في كييفا
التي تقدمت بطلب العضويه في سبتمبر الماضي
وتطالب باجراء مستعجل الامين العام للحلف
مقتنع عند منظمه ستفتح ابوابها يوما ما
لاوكرانيا
يجب ان تصبح عضوا في الحلم ولكن في الوقت
نفسه هذا سياخذ وقتا والاولويه الحاليه هي
ضمان بقاء اوكرانيا كدوله مستقله ذات
سياده وبالتالي يجب علينا دعم اوكرانيا
تحدث زعيم الناتو في هيلسنكي الى جانب
رئيسه الوزراء الفنلنديه سان مارين واعتبر
ان لطلبات العضويه من فنلندا والسويد
الاولويه المطلقه
جمع الاسره الشماليه معا حول طاوله الناتو
ستجعل فنلندا والسويد اكثر امانا
وحافه
على انضمامهما اما بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فقد
وعد قاده الناتو كييف في عام 2008 بانها
قد تنضم يوما ما الى الحلف سيتطلب هذا
الانضمام مره اخرى مصادقه جميع الدول
الاعضاء والبعض يشعر بالقلق من رده فعل
الكرملين فقد قال المتحدث باسم
الناتو في حرب الامر الواقع مع موسكو حيث
قال له بوتين ان القوه الغربيه تسعى
لتقسيم روسيا